cinta sobre la violencia en Nueva York
un drama histórico y la última entrega
de Indiana Jones acapararon el interés
en el festival de cannes
[Música]
el actor estadounidense John peng
suscitó la algarabía en cannes Al
momento de presentar en competencia
Black flight un Thriller basado en la
novela 911 del escritor estadounidense
Shannon sobre la vida y la muerte en las
violentas calles de Nueva York la
violencia es también el tema de la cinta
la zona de interés del británico
Jonathan glaiser esta película se sitúa
en la época del holocausto y cuenta la
historia de un oficial nazi y su familia
quienes viven tranquilamente entre
flores y colores justo al lado de un
campo de concentración y de Exterminio
la alfombra roja de cannes llegó a su
punto de ebullición con la presencia del
inigualable Harrison Ford protagonista
del quinto Indiana Jones proyectado
fuera de la competencia Harrison Ford
quien fue ovacionado por el público y
recibió una palma de oro de honor por
sorpresa un homenaje del festival de
cannes para este actor de leyenda que ha
marcado con Su carisma la historia del
cine